We now begin a series of lectures on
defenses and at the outset it's important
to make the point that defense and
maintenance are different things,
but they both originated
in homeostatic mechanisms.
Okay.
They evolved as modifications
of normal physiology
and a take home point for all of the
discussion of defense is that evolution
will tolerate high costs and will permit
significant vulnerabilities if it can
thereby gain major benefits.
And that is the reason that all associated
with every defense mechanism there is
a disease.
So just to distinguish between
homeostasis, maintenance and defense,
homeostasis is the stability
of key variables in cells,
tissues and organisms.
That's controlled by feedback mechanisms.
Most maintenance and defense mechanisms,
we're evolutionarily derived by
modifying homeostatic functions.
Okay.
Maintenance mechanism,
sustain normal function by preventing,
repairing and reducing malfunctions that
are byproducts of normal physiology.
Okay.
Defense mechanisms on the other hand,
protect against specific hostile
environmental perturbations that exceed
homeostatic capacity.
Yeah,
so if we look at that in
the form of a diagram,
we can start with developmental
and physiological processes.
They are affected by hostile environmental
factors and they are regulated by
homeostasis.
They produce deleterious byproducts.
The physiology and development and the
hostile environmental factors can produce
tissue deterioration, malfunction in
damage, as well as the normal processes.
So defense interferes with the
hostile environmental factors.
Hostile environmental factors interfere
with normal development and physiology.
Maintenance interferes with tissue
deterioration in malfunction.
So you can see that defense maintenance
and homeostasis or conceptually
separated.
Yeah.
Here's an example that makes
concrete these three processes.
Homeostasis is regulating protein
concentration in a cell by synthesis and
degradation.
Maintenance mechanisms are detecting
and clearing damaged proteins.
Viruses are detected by
the innate immune system,
which induces an antiviral defense.
Defenses, however, operate at
the expense of homeostasis.
During viral infection,
protein synthesis shuts down.
Defense increases the
concentration of damaged proteins,
which are then handled by
maintenance mechanisms.
So maintenance contributes to the
tolerance component of defense and the
mechanisms that eliminate the virus
represent the resistance component of
defense.
So there was a relationship between this
level of physiological analysis and the
distinction between
tolerance and resistance.
Yeah.
Now there are two types of maintenance.
There is constitutive and
inducible maintenance.
So here again,
we can start with the developmental
and physiological processes that are
degenerating byproducts
and tissue deterioration.
The constituency of maintenance
processes are those that are handling the
byproducts of normal
development and physiology.
The hostile environmental factors,
including pathogens,
are producing deleterious effects at the
physiological level and they are being
dealt with by inducible
maintenance programs.
The constituent of maintenance programs
compliment homeostasis and the inducible
programs compliment defense.
Yeah.
Here are some examples of
constitutive maintenance mechanisms.
The removal of damaged proteins
and lipids, so in aging,
that leads to neurodegeneration.
Yeah,
the detoxification and disposable and
disposal of metabolic waste products,
so with aging,
when that breaks down,
you get liver and kidney
insufficiency and disease.
The clearance of damaged
extracellular proteins with aging,
that leads to tissue degeneration.
Yeah.
Tissue renewal by stem cells with aging.
If that is not done properly,
there is cancer and other diseases.
Okay.
The maintenance of homeostatic mechanisms.
If that breaks down,
then aging can lead to type
two diabetes and osteoporosis.
Yeah.
The maintenance of tissues, that is
new, that are needed for defense,
which includes of course
the immune system. If that
breaks down. Then with aging,
we have increased
susceptibility to infections.
Examples of inducible
maintenance mechanisms,
those that are reacting to
environmental hostilities
have the characteristic
that when they're deployed,
normal maintenance mechanisms
ramp up to support them.
Yeah.
These include responses to starvation,
cold dehydration and hypoxia.
All of these are eroded by aging
and some organisms.
There is hibernation,
estivation, Dour Larvae,
sporulation Lord metabolic rate,
less need for oxygen,
food and water,
better protection of organs and tissues
and better resistance to stress,
greater tolerance of damage and
changed homeostatic set points,
so those would all be
radical restructurings of
underlying physiology to deal
with unavoidable environmental stress.
Okay.
If we contrast inducible and
constituent of processes,
we see that constituent of
maintenance operates all the time.
It doesn't trade off with growth or
reproduction within a single organism.
Constituent of maintenance is not
trading off with growth and reproduction.
Inducible maintenance responds to
hostile challenges to promote survival.
Well,
it reduces growth and reproduction.
Yeah,
reduced maintenance compromises.
Both homeostasis and defense both need
to be maintained at the population level.
However,
maintenance we'll trade off with growth
and reproduction if it is negatively,
genetically correlated.
So this statement is about
physiological tradeoffs,
and this statement is about evolutionary
and genetically based tradeoffs.
Okay.
Defenses that are only needed on demand
and that have high costs have evolved to
be inducible.
So the immune responses are inducible.
Yeah.
Defenses that are always needed.
Our constituent IV,
that includes barrier
defenses such as skin.
Okay.
To summarize,
homeostasis,
maintenance and defense
are intimately related.
Okay.
Maintenance and defense mechanisms are
extensions of homeostasis mechanisms,
and they are often
evolutionarily derived from them.
That's important because it means that
maintenance and maintenance and defense
mechanisms bring with their
evolutionary heritage,
the advantages and the vulnerabilities
of that evolutionary heritage.
Homeostasis,
maintenance,
and defense all have both
constitutive and inducible components.
Whether the constituent or inducible
mode of operation evolves depends on the
demand and the cost.